[Music]
in the more you know news submitted by
kingpin slim the actress Marcia Cross
learned in her anal cancer was likely
caused by the same virus as her husband
stroke cancer she was eaten too but he
was either her but that's literally 1 /
1 - I didn't know cancer was contagious
yeah no catch was contagious like that
tick a little bit that is what Matthew
get the prescription you'll one for you
know one yeah we all know that that for
blood cancer goes on the but they put
the pill there in the throat though how
did that cancer transfer into the
[ __ ] maybe that's all it transferred
to the throat the throat hall you know
Sam I do know what you're saying
and I like it like what he's here yo
there's I know this girl that she um
it's my girlfriend's friend and she's
like she was talking to this a cellist
I'll in like the UK whatever he's like
traveling and um super famous and he has
this random fetish that she wanted he
wanted her to fart in his mouth oh those
guys are amazing dude yes and what she
said was like you know she she randomly
said it at the time and he like he was
just like you know they're good he's
eating her as they he just goes like
farting in my mouth and she's like I
don't have to fart so they have an
awkward moment of like hurt trying to
push me and try to get him one to come
out what if she comes out nothing she
says she said that she couldn't far it
was like a weird like thing she couldn't
park I don't know farting on command is
a talent though it was literally like
they had to they like they didn't happen
that's that Tom and then they went out
on a date and she said that she she
ain't something that would say in her
head she's like trying to press into
where she that's tight sheep red for the
fart damn that's a lover right yeah she
told my girl he told her some of my
girls to giving me this the story she's
just like she knew that that Tasha was
just like I hope we can do this again
you know I mean I'm
oh that's so disgusting and he got the
most gnarly pinkeye the both of them
like like literally literally it's like
he had to go like the ER because hit the
pinkeye was that bad and then they've
got like there's fecal matter somehow
and then if I made out yeah the death of
how far people will go to please each
other can I have more that means the
whole time she's eating their [ __ ]
loading up on beads like Marc so [ __ ]
hard in this fools mouth to make him
happy
can you believe that she what do you do
with the portly man wonder like what do
you do with it yes is he burp oh and it
comes out he sucks it in and then blows
it on his nose oh yeah smell it again if
he's thinking about girls
like farting when he's playing cello cuz
sometimes when you're doing music you
feel it but you're thinking about things
that you are in a play cello
he's a cellist yeah dude your friend
goes by a smelly movie theater
restaurant and he's like okay airplane
seat yeah I sat behind one one it
smelled so bad and I'm like okay oh yeah
no random I never smelled the airplane
see like that you ever really put your
nose in an airplane seat I don't need to
get my feet down low to smell it you can
smell it [ __ ] gross anyway so Marcia
Cross she's an actress she came out in
Desperate Housewives have no idea I was
wrong
who did you think it was I thought it
was the one of the Sex in the City girls
Oh like Samantha or something no the
other one the brunette one the one
nobody talks about oh that one so
Jessica this is her husband oh so he had
throat cancer back in 2009 it's funny
when you see that picture and then the
thing is he eats her ass is what you
think of that's what's so crazy when you
see sleep
so he went into remission after you know
like battling the cancer but then nearly
a decade later the same disease came up
again when Marcia Cross was diagnosed
with anal cancer and so the doctors
suspect that the cancers came from the
same type of HPV like human papilloma
virus yeah which is a STD and so they're
saying like that same strand strand yeah
whatever
that's caused that but why I decided to
camp in her but I don't know or like in
his throat who knows but now she's just
saying lord
maybe his throat smells bad they
actually discovered her anal cancer by
you know this is one doctor it was just
very very thorough and so he did like a
rectal exam and they found out that
wasn't it's our team Brett knows a word
that's uncomfortable for me right is it
really called anal cancer anal cancer
they call it Heather she said like she
used to hate thing that word too but
then now is just like she's just said it
so much worried just like it she's not
embarrassed about it anymore and she she
battles it like she doesn't have it no
more and she said that she had to I
really rely on her girlfriends who she
called her anal angels because here
inherited sounds like a porn er you just
can't make things everything cute it
just sounds like like those group of
girls that go to Vegas and they all have
like a sash that says like anal Angels
have brown wings it's right rhinestoned
it out yeah but yeah so then they're
saying that anal cancer is very curable
if you find it like soon and now she's
just saying that she wants to talk about
it and not make it so like shameful
because a lot of the people it is shame
but you just keep it to herself
[Laughter]
ashamed of admitting where their cancer
is you don't see a lot of parades where
it says anal cancer and ribbon color is
it brown anal cancer awareness it should
be a starfish that's that's cute yeah
yeah what are the symptoms of anal
cancer don't tell me flu-like symptoms
oh my god let me google it it's like if
you're bleeding out of your [ __ ] or
something
that's not bleeding out of your butthole
rectal itching a lump or mass at the
anal opening sounds like hemorrhoids
does sound like hemorrhoid pain or
feeling of fullness in the anal area
narrowing of stool or other changes in
bowel movement that all sounds like
hemorrhoid abnormal discharge from the
enos colon or lymph nodes in the anal or
groin areas yeah just may be nervous for
the next like itchy [ __ ] like that's
what I'm saying right so I'm like being
a no cancer wouldn't wish it on my worst
enemy the itchy [ __ ] is real a real
stubborn one that is like I haven't had
a HD [ __ ] in a while but I had it
when I was a kid a lot me too you were a
nasty-ass kid I remember like [ __ ]
always trying to [ __ ] get my ass to
the lake feel better
it was like goddamn do the wrong
on the shears I never seen streaks in my
GI Joe underwear I swear I [ __ ] clean
that [ __ ] mm-hmm it came from wiping bad
my mom had a [ __ ] watch me watch my
ass because I was getting so much [ __ ]
streaks she was like [ __ ] are you doing
this and she had to like tell me to keep
going until it's completely out damn you
are a DD with strong still hot because
you're like alright that's it we just go
back into the playground then you just
wipe in my yeah I don't even remember
but she told me this story and she told
me she she well I basically had a
[ __ ] learning disability because what
she told me was like I didn't hold
chopsticks right because um when I was i
I visited her recently and then she was
like oh you hold chopsticks right now
and I'm like what are you talking about
and she's like yeah I used to hold it
funny I'm like oh yeah I remember that I
learned off of a back of of the a
wrapper right on how to hold chopsticks
the right way yeah the right way right
so this is this is how I used to hold it
like this right I kind of just squeezed
it like that right I used to squeeze it
like that you had no food on yeah but
then I mean I do it the right way now
right and then she was like when you're
a kid that's more the generic way right
I don't know this is right way I'm also
a girl she goes yeah he'll show you he's
got the good skills right yeah it
doesn't matter well basically she was
like the New York when you're a kid I
[ __ ] gave up on teaching you how to
do chopsticks or anything because I
would try different methods I kept
trying to do try a different you know
ways and you just wouldn't listen
that's what have a mean of forks I'm
sure you guys have seen this I'm [ __ ]
hold Forks like this I just do a right
way to do it it's like some [ __ ] like
this yeah but this actually no you don't
I would because I got hit this is how
you do like this you put a stance when
you're cutting that's about it though
in the new switch yeah
but are you doing it you're doing it
that's how you eat know which house
things like um the rice that like okay
you don't get a lot of rice on on the
rice oh my god cuz you could also shape
it to like it's like clay you could
shape it in and pick it up that won't
clump together so that's a [ __ ] and
I'll just go off what [ __ ] my doing I'll
hold it to a fork
get a fork every time listen this is an
ancient tool okay a fork is a more
modern it's a surgical tool been
scientifically proven that your brain
gets smarter when you use I could drink
soup with this Steve yeah I don't need
to try to figure out how to get rice
when I can just get rise Steve picked
small little meat pieces off of a fish
bone there's no way chopsticks small
VG's up I use my hands yeah your mouth
cuz he's a barbarian he hold this
[ __ ] utensils like this or I'm like
this fish bones done hey all the meat
off and is it more of like a respect
thing when like like getting Asian food
and then getting chopsticks are you
choosing to are you to the chopsticks
sport as a respect thing or to the
chopsticks to be impressive well you
know I mean like this guy know anybody
anybody like I do whatever the cultures
like you know when you go to like an
Ethiopian restaurant that's a lot with
the hands uh-huh so for me I just tried
to do it because I feel like it tastes
better that's how they cook that's how
they meant to make a serve it yes if I'm
a to eat the open restaurant I just use
my hands I don't use a fork or spoon or
anything let me tell you what I do but
I'm in a sushi restaurant or seventies
dress or anything what I'm done put my
chopsticks
in the rice and on that signals to the
waiter that I'm done well cuz supposed
to mimic incense
like someone died so you're not supposed
to put it in the rice up or the noodles
Casey told me noodles you would actually
have me a piece of [ __ ] and now would it
cover correct
oh babe you have to in the ride ruined
it
he's like smiling he's like see if you
ruined that basically if I show the way
I put it in so the right way is you
stick it you stick it in like this and
you go and then you fight walk away
that's a note they - it's a
disrespectful to do forks and like a
deuce none of that none of it is yeah
yeah none of it is it's just preference
that's why I just challenged myself like
you know I'm gonna do dude there's
nothing more you were disrespectful try
stupid rights like this the weird like
Jesus [ __ ] have a fork already
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]